(tirs)
- Nous sommes à Pripyat, début
février. Des combattants ennemis
sesese sont emparés de positions
clés dans la ville ukrainienne.
(tirs)
Mais leurs forces sont
affaiblies. C'est le moment
idéal pour les forces de
sécurité ukrainiennes pour
les neutraliser et reprendre
le contrôle de la ville.
(tirs)
Reconnaissance aérienn
et tireurs d'élite,
(coup de feu)
ce sont les troupes
du Ministère de l'intérieur
qui lancent l'....
Des secouristes formés
par le Canada viennent en aide
à la population civile,
(tirs)
pendant que les combats
se poursuivent.
Les bombes sont désamorcées, des
foyers d'incendies sont éteints.
L'opération de reconquête est un
succès, non sans que les forces
ukrainiennes ne subissent des
blessures.
Dans les fait, tout ça, c'est
un exercice qui vise à préparer
la police nationale aux combats
urbains. Les civils sont
des acteurs. Pripyat est une
ville désertée depuis l'accident
nucléaire de Tchernobyl, le
décor parfait pour simuler des
affrontements en pleine ville.
En cas dn n n n n russe,
ces jeunes hommes seront
mieux préparés à une guerre,
imminente, inévitable diront
plusieurs.
(tir)
Si tous les yeux sont rivés
sur l'important arsenal
militaire de la Russie,
qui manoeuvre aux frontières de
l'Ukraine, il n'est pas la seule
arme dont il faut s'inquiéter.
L'attaque des Russes a déjà
commencé. Elle n'est pas le fait
de lance-missiles ou de chars
blindés, mais plutôt menée
dans l'ombre, depuis l'anonymat
de serveurs informatiques
ou derrière le masque
de la désinformation.
NATALIA TKACHUK, Centre national
coordination pour cybersécurité
- L'Ukraine est sur la ligne
de front de ces cybermenaces
depuis 2014, et pas que d'un
point de vue de cybernétique,
mais aussi d'un point de vue
de l'information. Je parle
de manipulation de la société,
parce que souvent, nous voyons
que les cyberattaques ne visent
pas qu'à perturber nos sssssss
mais à semer la panique pour
influencer l'opinion publique.
- C'est ce que l'on appelle
la guerre hybride et c'est
une guerre à laquelle l'Ukraine
est bien peu préparée.
Dans le tout nouveau
Centre de coordination de
la cybersécurité, on surveille
t t t t t t t les attaques
quotidiennes contre l'Ukraine.
Cette carte interactive montre
en direct une partie de ces
attaques. L'activité donne le
vertige. Des dizaines, voire des
centaines de milliers d'attaques
sont détectées tous les jours.
Mais toutes n'ont pas
lecococococococonséquences.- Elr
une base régulière et elles
deviennent de plus en plus
difficiles et sévères. Elles
sont ciblées. En fait, depui
fin octobre, ces cyberattaques
sont devenues plus graves et
nous comprenons bien pourquoi.
- Le 14 janvier dernier, alors
que les tensions entre la Russie
et l'Ukraine était à leur
brbrbrbrbrbrbrbreux sites
gouvernementaux ont été piratés.
Kiev a démenti un vol de données
pendant l'attaque et a accusé
la Russie d'être responsable.peé
fait partie de la Cyberalliance
ukrainienne, un regroupement
citoyen de pirates aux
intentions bienveillantes, les
chapeaux blancs. L'Ukraine
minimise la menace, croit-il.
SEAN TOWNSED
Cyberalliance de l'Ukraine
- Ils ne sont toujours pas
preparés pour faire face aux
attaques Russes, par
seul jour, les Russes ont réussi
à fermer la moitié des sites
publiques de notre gouvernements
de plusieurs ministères.
- Aujourd'hui, c'était
du ministère de la Défense
et de banque privées de faire
les frais d'attaques qui
ont surchargé leurs systèmes,pa.
- Nos vis-à-vis russes au sein
des unités de piratage du FSB et
des renseignements russes sont
très à l'aise dans les systèmes
quququququququququque personne,
personne ne peut les arrêter.
- Dans le sous-sol de cette
université de Kiev, on surveille
aussi les attaques des Russes.
Les moyens techniques y sontplpe
semaine, c'est ici que la
plateforme StopFake expose
la désinformation véhiculée
par les médias russes.
- C'est dangereux.
C'est dommageable.
- Ruslan Deynychenko s'adresse
à la population russophone
de l'Ukraine.
À chaque épis
présente un condense de fausses
informations rapportées par
les chaînes officielles
de la Russie.RUSLAN DEYNYCHENKOe
- C'est un acte de guerre.
C'est un peu différent comme
type de guerre, mais ça reste
une guerre et c'est
efficace que des opérations au
sol avec des chars et d'autres
armes. La propagande est
une arme au même titre quelelels
et c'est encore plus efficace.
- StopFake se penche uniquement
sur ce que l'on pourrait
qualifier de propagande
officielle, celles des grandsdi,
c'est par l'entremise des
réseaux sociaux qui se propage
l'information fausse, anxiogène
et clivante.
Faux profils et trolls sont
autant de petits soldats au
service de cette guerre hybride.
La semaine dernière, lestétététt
annoncé avoir démantelé une
usine de trolls qui, selon
elles, propageait la panique
sur les réseaux sociaux.
Les quelque 18 000 comptes
robotisés découverts dans cette
usine d'un
l'ouest du pays ont aussi servi
à placer de nombreux appels
à la bombe dans les écoles,
contribuant à un climat de peur.
Tous ces comptes étaient
supervisés par des Russes,
selon le Service de Sécurité
ukrainiens.
Trois hommes ont été arrêtés.
Une petite victoire,
mais le combat reste entier.
- Nous devons pouvoir riposter
contre l'agresseur. C'est pourç,
nous créons une cyberforce
militaire qui pourra défendre
notre pays.
- Sur les lignes de frontdédédéa
pas de tranchées, pas de cibles
stratégiques dans la ligne de
mire. Mais le fameux brouillard
de la guerre y est d'aut
épai